abone ol
O çok teşekkürler hepinizi sevgi ve
saygıyla selamlıyorum çok güzel
konuşmalar oldu benden önce bir çok
güzel açılımlar da yaptılar biraz
kafamda bunlara doğru yönlendi doğrusu
kelimelerden bahsettik kelimelerden ve
kavramlardan Bugün aslında çok önemli
kavramlar üzerinde bir toplantı yapılmış
kuşakların Keşke üzerinden konuşacağız
ama kelimelerin Aslında hayatımızda ne
kadar kifayetsiz olduğunu da çok
sıklıkla fark edebildiğimiz durumlarla
karşılaşıyoruz Üstat Halil Cibran şöyle
diyor düşünceler kelimelerin kafesine
takılmış Kuşlar gibidir o kafesin içinde
kanatlarını Açabilir ama asla uçamaz
kelimeler düşünmemize yardımcı olan çok
teknik araçlar Ve üstelik insan
uygarlığının gelişimi kelimelerin
sayısının artışıyla Çok doğru orantılı
Çek bir döneminden beş kat daha fazla
İngilizce kelime kullanılıyor
hayatımızda
en çok kelime Yüzyıl öncesinde yok
Telefon yok televizyon yok diş macunu
yok Sabah kalkıyoruz duş yok Bot yok
elektrikli araba yok gemi Yok birkaç yıl
öncesine gidene kadar yani her uygarlık
dönüşümüyle heryeri geçen zamanla
yepyeni kelimelerle Bu kelimelerle
örülmüş yepyeni kafeslerle iç içe
yaşıyoruz o kafesin içinde Yaşıyoruz
çünkü kelimeler aynı zamanda
düşüncelerimizin tutsaklığı anlamına da
geliyor ve kelimeleri kim üretiyorsa
kavramları kim üretiyorsa düşünceleri
belirleyen zihinlerin efendiside onlar
oluyorlar kafeslerimiz in gardiyanları
onlar oluyorlar o yüzden de kelimelere
anlam veren leri kelimeleri kullananları
araçsallaştırma anları iyi görmek ve ona
göre pozisyon almak gerekiyor Mesela
hepimiz çok belirgin kelimeleri olumlu
değerler veriyoruz Sevgi gibi aşk gibi
Barış gibi ya da çocuğu anlamlar yüklü
bu köfke nefret savaş gibi içimiz de hiç
savaşın iyi olduğunu düşünenler var mı
ya da barışın kötü olduğunu düşünen
kimse var mı
Yok yok Bu çok doğal bir şey Barış aydır
Savaş kötüdür Peki o zaman soruyorum
size milli mücadelemizin başladığı
şehirden Soruyorum neden biz sevgi Barış
Antlaşması'nı imzalamak da Kurtuluş
Savaşı yaptık kötü olduğumuz için mi
bütün savaşlar Aslında temelde bir
barışa ulaşmak içindir ama o barışı
kimin yaptığı çok önemlidir Barış son
savaşın son galibinin oluşturduğu
statüko dur ve statik onu sahipleri Yani
bir önceki savaşın galipleri barışçıldır
O yüzden de barışı onlar çok güzel bir
şey olarak tanımlarlar o statükoyu
değiştirip kendi barışını korumak
isteyen herkeste Onlara göre kötüdür
devizyon ister anarşisttir güzel
yakıcıdır Şudur budur bütün savaşlar
bunun için yapılmıştır 20 yüzyıl boyunca
tam 200 milyon insan siyasi nedenlerle
hayatını kaybetmiştir insan eliyle
öldürülmüştür savaşlarda öldürmüşlerdir
rejim konsolidasyon larında öldürür
ve iç çatışmalarda öldürmüşlerdir mezhep
savaşlarında öldürmüşlerdir İnsanlığın
en karanlık yüzyıldır 20 yüzyıl Ve
üstelik birilerini öldüren insanlar
hiçbir Kötü değildir hep çok iyi
amaçlarla öldürmüşlerdir bir İkinci
Dünya Savaşı'nda yaşıma ve ne gazetenin
orta yerine şehirlere bomba atan Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri kimse soykırımda
suçlamıştır ama verse anlaşmasına maruz
bırakılan Almanya soykırımdır Japonya
yargılanmıştır savaşı Kaybedenler
mutlaka yargılanır ve savaşın suçunu
tazminat borçlarını hepsini ödemek
zorunda kalırlar Çünkü her şey bir güç
mücadelesidir kavramlar masum değildir
kavramlarının anlamları vardır politik
Anlamları vardır Ben bir Politik bir
olduğu için siyaset bir olduğu için
doğal olarak size kuşaklar meselesinin
politik yönlerini Anlatmaya çalışacağım
biraz da eleştiren duracağım Müsadenizle
Çünkü kuşak yapımı duyduğum zaman
bu üzerinde çok tartışılan 80'li
yıllardan itibaren i.p.c. konuşulmaya
başlayan 21'inci yüzyıla girdiğimiz
andan itibaren de uzun uzun anlatılan
üzerinde kitaplar yazılan konferanslar
verilen bir süreçten bahsediyoruz
Generation birinin üzerinden işte sessiz
kuşak üstüne beybi bulunurlar ve bebek
patlaması kuşağı ilk kuşağı y kuşağı az
ayakuşa Hani kuşağından birisiyim bir
hepimizin hayatını Birlik Uşakları belli
yıllara göre ayrı po dönümü sosyal
kültürel ortamında yaşayan insanların
paylaştıkları ortak değerlere öncelik ön
plana çıkartıp birtakım tanımlamalar
yaptılar bunu yaparken Şu soruyu
sormamız gerekiyor Bu kavramlar
gerçekten Belli bir zaman diliminde
belli bir sosyal kültürel ortamın içinde
yaşayan insanları tanımıyor mu
var yani kavram tanımlayıcı bir şey mi
burada yoksa kavram paketleyici bir şey
olarak mı kullanıyor yani kullandığımız
kavramı aslında bir şeyleri anlatmak
için için mi yoksa bir şeyler üretmek
için mi İcat ediyoruz bakın Samuel
huntington 1989'da fences okuyamadığı
yazı tarihi sonu tezinin hemen akabinde
onu alternatif olarak bir kuram
geliştirdi dedi ki uygarlıklar çatışması
var Önümüzdeki dönemdeki çatışmanın en
önemli sebebi din referanslı olarak
belirlenen uygarlıkların uzlaşmazlık
olacak İslam ve diğerleri arasında
olacak büyük ölçüde ama Konfüçyüs İslam
ortaklığı olabilir söz konusu olabilir
ve insanlar birtakım uygarlıkları tasnif
etmeye ikna edildiler İslam bir
uygarlıkta bir kalıptır ve İslam budur
tanımı budur bugün Batı dünyasının
gözündeki İslam'ın resmi işitir
sakalıdır örtülüdür Şudur budur kafasına
İslam algısı paketlenmiştir bir kere
İslam uygarlığı bir kavramının
ben seni onun için içine zihinlerimizin
Efendi dediğimiz O Büyük güçler
istedikleri contenti yerleştirilen içeri
yerleştirilebilirler Batı dedikleri şey
onların ürettiği bir kavramdır nasıl
Nisa nasıl oluyorsa aynı topraklardan
çıkar Batı uygarlığına simgesi olan
hıristiyanlığı üretir aynı topraklarda
Müslümanlık ya da Yahudilik çıkar ama
onlar bot olarak tanımlanmaya bilirler O
yüzden kavramın nasıl üretildiği ve ne
işe yaradığını çok iyi tarif etmek
gerekir bugünkü dünyada nasıl bir islâmi
uygarlık kalıbı oluşturuldu ve içine
bütün İslam ülkeleri Malezya'dan
Amerika'daki Müslümana Afrika'daki
müslümandan Türk Müslümanlar
sekillerinden vah abisine ihvan-ı
Müslimin hepsi birden içine koydular sa
Bugün de kuşak denilen şeyler aslında
aynı şeyi yapıyorlar Bu şarkı teorisi
Aslında Külliyen Batı tarafından
üretilmiş ve kapitalist güçlerin
emellerine hizmet etmek için yapılmış
bu olan bir kavramlar bütünü bana göre
neden birincisi tarihsel değil
var Yani bütün on binlerce yıllık insan
uygarlığını sadece Yüzyıl içerisinde
tarihleme çalışıyorlar Yüzyıllık bir
tarif daha öncesi yok gibi harika
uygarlıklar on binlerce yıllık tarım
uygarlığı yüz binlerce yıllık Sanayi
uygarlığına doğru geliyorsunuz yüzlerce
yıllık Sanayi uygarlığına Ondan sonra
birkaç oynadık Sanayi sonrası
uygarlığına yani gittik gittikçe
hızlanan bir akış var ama uygarlıkları
arasında binler yüzler onlar da giden
bir akış içerisinde insan tabiatını
değiştirecek ölçüde değişimi dayatan bir
dönüşüm var tarihinde bütün uzattı
dönemlerde bu kesin ama nasıl oluyor da
sadece 20 yüzyıl boyunca insanlık var
olmuş gibi bu kuşaklara giriyoruz ve
onları bir yandan İşte bu kuşak bencil
bu kuşak çok iyi Bucak çok masum bu
kuşak şunu sever bu kuşak bunu sever bu
kuşak şöyle davranır kuşak böyle
davranırdı klasifiye ediyoruz kategorize
diyoruz Bu ne işe yarıyor tarihsel
olmamak zat
Bu kavramın çok da doğru tanımlanmadığı
gösteren en önemli şeydir kökünü
bulamazsınız nasıl olmuştur Üstelik aynı
şeylerden şikayet eden yüzlerce binlerce
yıl öncesinde yaşayan felsefecileri
siyaset bilimciler de görmeniz mümkün
sadece tarihsel değildir bir biyolojik
gelişim sürecinin anlatısı olduğu için
de eksiktir Belki belki Sokrates'in
aristonu falan şikayet ettiği o
gençlikte bizim şikayet ettiğimiz
gençliğin aynısıdır Belki bu biyolojik
bir farklılıktır sadece yaşlanmakla veya
genç olmakla ilintili bir şey olabilir
bu Belki biz yaşlılar gençlere göre
yaşlıyız çok önemli bir travmanın
Aslında sonucu olarak gençliği
ötekileştiriyorsunuz dur küçültüyoruz
dur kızıyoruz dur öfkeleniyor uzdur
regresyona giriyoruz dur yani çekinmeye
geriye dönmeye başlıyoruz dur içimize
kapanıyoruz Dur Belki kaybettiğimiz
şeyin büyüklüğünün farkındayız
Gençliğimizi tazeliğini Umut etmeyi
Yarın düşünmeyi kaybedip Sadece anı
yaşamak zorunda kalmanın öfkesine
travmasını yaşadığımız için o
gençlerdeki vurdumduymazlık gelecek
yarın nasılsa yarın yaparım
ertelemecilik delikanlılıkta ki bunlar
da sinirinizi bozan şey Sokrates'in de
sinir bozulmuş belki Ortada ortada genel
olarak bütün tarihlerin tarihin bütün
dönemlerinin şikayetlerinin aynısı
vardır böyle bir şeyden bahsediyor
olabiliriz
ve biyolojik olabilir ve tarih dışı
olabilir bir kavram ama geçerli olabilir
bu nasıl olur E çünkü o dönemin
pazarlama tekniklerine o dönemin
ekonomisine hizmet eden bir kavram
olabilir bu yüzden çok işe yarıyor
olabilir kitaplar yazılıyor
üniversitelerde çalışmalar yapılıyor şu
oluyor bu oluyor sanat bu yöne doğru
gidiyor neden Kapitalizm buna ihtiyaç
duyuyor kapitalizmin Çünkü kanda
noktalar var çünkü mal satmak zorunda ve
malı Satarken de fabrikadan çıkan
yüzbinlerce malı Şu anda şu sıralarda
herkese kastım acıdı kişiye özel şeyler
yapıyorlar ama o kişiyi özelliği bile
toplumsallaştırma ve kitlesel eleştirmiş
durumda olduklarını göz ardı etmeyelim
Yapay Zeka data analizi dataların
toplanma süreçleri bunların tamamı bütün
insanlığı aslına bakarsanız bir
pazarlama nesnesi haline getiriyor
tanıyor ve satmak istiyor satarken
kolaylaştırıcı Faktör ne mi
o kadar paketler siniz Z koşan şöyle
davranır yeni koşa böyle davranır e y
kuşağı için bir içecek üretir Z kuşağı
için bir içecek üretirsiniz Peki Z
kuşağı gerçekten öyle olduğu için bu
tanımı yapıyoruz yoksa dünyadaki bütün o
yaş grubunu Sen Z boşalır böyle
davranmalısın diye Manipüle mi ediyoruz
yapılmakta olan şey Z kuşağı anlatmak mı
zevk uşağını yaratmak mı Ya da y
kuşağını yaratmak mı
ve yapay zekanın robotina yepyeni üretim
sistemlerinin blok çiçeğinin devreye
girdiği altyapının değiştiği bir
ortamdaki altyapı her değiştiği
değiştirme üst yapıda değişiklikler olur
altyapının değişimine yardımcı olacak o
değişimi yansıtacak yepyeni bir ruhla
şekillendirilmiş yeni bir insanlık mı
üretiliyor yeni bir insanlık yeni bir
politika yeni bir inanışlar silsilesi
üretiliyor temel mesele ekonomik
ortamdaki değişiklik mi mize koşa
çalışmayı sevmiyor y kuşağı çalışmayı
sevmiyorum Belki de zaten çalışmak çok
Makul bir şey olacak bundan sonra
robotlar çalışacak Zaten iş yok yok o
zaman Z kuşağı rahattır bir biyolojik
farklıdır uzun uzun uyumak ister uyusun
zaten Uyanmazsan ne yapacak uyandı sabah
yedide kalktığı zaman ne yapacak bu
çocuklar otursunlar sosyal nedeni
burasında geç saatlere kadar eğlensinler
yani bunlarla uğraşıyorsun Her şey bir
o zincirleme bir biçimde gelişiyor
olabilir mi mi kapitalizmi icat icat
edenler aynı zamanda çok önemli bir
eksiklik Dede Yüzleştir yiyorlar bizi bu
bahsettiğimiz kuşakların tamamı aslında
coğrafi açıdan da bakıldığında kültürel
açıdan da bakıldığında sadece batıyı
tarifeden tanımlar dır bebibu kuşağı
denilen kavramın ortaya çıkışını bir tek
sebebi vardır 1945'te 1960 yılları
arasında Yani savaş sonrası dönemde
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde 70 8.2
milyon bebek doğmuştur Amerika'nın savaş
kazanmış ekstra büyük bir şey var refah
ortamı var ve savaş dönemlerinde
psikolojisi İnsanoğlu hayatta
kalmışlığını cinsellikle sevgiyle
şefkatli ve to almakla kutluyor böyle
anlıyor yaşıyorum Savaş dönemlerinde
çocuk patlaması olur üstümüze Bombalar
Yağarken sevişir siniz
bu sistem böyle de bunun psikolojisi var
olacaksınız tutunun dur bu Bu yüzden de
ve bunu kuşağı savaşa maruz kalan
ülkelerde çok hızlı bir çoğalmayı da
sağlamıştır ama Afrika için önce
söyleyemezsiniz Hatta şunu söyleyeyim
dünyada çoğalma hızına bakıldığında
1945'te 1960 yılları arasında yüzde
18'dir 1980 yılında da yüzde 18'dir
60'tan sonra 122y çıkmıştır Yani 45-60
yılları arasında dünya sathında bir
aşırı bebek doğumu diye bir şey söz
konusu değildi Amerika'da söz konusu ya
kuşak çatışmaları Amerika uçak
çalışmaları Amerika merkezli olarak
üretilmiştir bir aynı şey
bu Türkiye'de Afganistan'da İran'da
Avrupa'da antartika'da yaşayan gençlerin
kapsarmı ya da yaşları kapsarmı hepimiz
aynı iki kuş almışız hepimiz aynı
şeyleri mi savunduk aynı evlerin içinde
mi büyüdük içimizde inançlarımıza inanç
kızımız var liberal imiz var Sosyalist
imiz var kadınımız var erkeği miz var
etnik olarak farklılıklarımız var göç
etmiş olanlarımız var yerleşik lerimiz
var bir ülkeden sürülmüş olan
milyonlarca Suriyeli ile oops kuşağıyla
benim aynı olmam şu anda aynı şeyler
düşünmem aynı işi isteklerimin olması
aynı taleplerinin olması makul mu mümkün
mü böyle bir şey Afrikalı Leo ile
Amerikalı joe'nun aynı yıllarda dolmuş
olsalar bile aynı şeyleri Hayal etmeleri
mümkün mü bu O yüzden kuşak
çalışmalarına baktığımızda ilk siyezevi
gibi kuşakların sadece kapitalist
pazarın yayılabildiği olanlarda Sağ
O belli merkezlerde anlam kazandığını
görebilirsiniz tarih dışı olduğu kadar
tarihi dışladığı kadar insanlığın da
dışındadır bu üretilmiş masa başında
üretilmiş bir kuşaklar teorisinden
bahsediyoruz sadece işlevseldir ve bugün
böyle bir işlevselliğini pazarlanması
için ellerinin altında inanılmaz bir
Network iletişim araçları her an
herkesin evine kadar fiber optik
kablolardan üst taraftaki dalgalardan
gidebilen imkanlar vardır Artık Bizler
bir dünyada yaşamıyoruz Bizler bir
dünyayı yaşıyoruz ve gittikçe insanlık
bir dünya Yaşar hale geliyor kuşak
çalışmaları başka tür tanımlamaları da
dönüşecektir Önümüzdeki dönemde Çünkü
pazar Bunu istiyor Önümüzdeki dönemde
inanç sistemlerine yönelik yepyeni
akımlar olacaktır bakın Müslümanın 50
milyon kişiye ulaşması hıristiyanlığın
50 milyon kişiye ulaşması dinle
200-300 öğretisinin budizmin 50 milyon
kişiye ulaşması yüzlerce yıl almıştır
Bugün sadece baktığınız zaman Angry
Birds oyununun Onbeş gün içinde 50
milyon kişi ulaşabildiğiniz görüyorsunuz
herhangi bir aplikasyon internet üzeri
Şehit mobil telefonlar üzerinden
indirilen aplikasyon 24 saat içinde 50
milyon kişinin telefonuna
indirilebiliyor böyle bir Dünyanın içine
böyle bir yayılma trendinin içinde
yaşıyoruz epidemik ler yani salgınlar
yayılacak bilgiler yayılacak düzenler
yayılacak ve Herbir ortaya çıkan yeni
düzen kendi kuşakların üretecek çünkü
kendi ideallerini kendi fikirlerini
kendi satış stratejilerini kolayca
kabulle ne bilecek Zaten önceden
formatlanmış ve kalıplanmış ve Aslında
insanlıktan çıkartılmış bireylere
ihtiyacı var Bu heryeri sistemin işte
politik psikoloji de bunlarla uğraşıyor
ben de
Ben onlarla uğraştım için size kısacık
bir kubbe vermek istedim neleri
çalıştığımızı neleri anlamaya gayret
ettiğimiz göstermek bakımından Çok
teşekkür ederim